hello everyone another day another day
another day another dollar yeah I guess
you could say that okay so what's the
story today well I was gonna go in to
continue with the Adam but I'm gonna
have to postpone that because we have
like an emergency that came up and
that's the issue of what is philosophy
and they they that came up in yeah
because you know let's put in the right
context I put philosophy under science
I'm saying philosophy is a branch of
science that's not what and people out
there typically understand by philosophy
people out there think that philosophy
is just oh it's a way of thinking your
way of thinking your philosophy you know
that's the notion people have in the
back of their minds today I'm gonna
argue that's ordinary speech it's not
scientific language and you can say well
philosophy is not part of science and
I'm gonna argue exactly the opposite I'm
gonna say that philosophy is a branch of
science and the reason we need it is
that we have physics which deal with
objects mechanisms and causes and then
we have to have some way of explaining
because science is about explaining
right we have to have a way of
explaining things related to concepts
such as love intelligence information
those kinds of things you know these are
concepts and we have to be able to deal
with also with reasons and purpose what
are we going to call that well I decided
to call it philosophy and let me tell
you why it all comes down to the
definition of philosophy and let's start
there let's let's see what philosophy
means first from a historical point of
view I'm gonna go kind of Swift dear but
try to keep in mind that you know we're
trying to get into a definition of
philosophy okay
this is where it starts we have here
this is an old version of philosophy it
comes from ancient times
and essentially it says looked
philosophy is the love of wisdom okay
the study of general and fundamental
problems concerning matters such as
existence knowledge values reason mind
and language that's what the big
wikipedia says in other words they
bunched everything in their existence
ontology knowledge which is epistemology
values reason mind language cooking so
we you know everything is philosophy is
everything
that's essentially what these people are
saying where did they get all this well
it says in the early stages of Greek
this comes from now from the Catholic
Encyclopedia and by the way it's
interesting to note that the Stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy does not have
a definition of philosophy that's kind
of interesting they do have a definition
of knowledge which meet it which is we
don't know what it is that's the
definition it means too many people use
it with too many different that's part
of the problem but it's it's deeper than
that and I will show that today you know
it says look in the early stages of
Greek as of every other civilization so
it's not only the Greeks right we're
talking about the Eastern religions all
these all these philosophers etc the
boundary line between philosophy and
other departments of human knowledge was
not sharply defined and philosophy was
understood to mean every strive every
striving towards knowledge ever there
everything striving towards I I must
have missed the word I don't know but it
says every striving toward maybe I
erased the word there maybe it's
everything striving towards now to every
you know pursuit striving towards
knowledge and it says okay it continues
it says look what is now knowledge of
the causes and reasons of things Plato
called it the acquisition of knowledge
Aristotle called it first causes and
principles and philosophy is the science
which considers first and universal
causes wisdom considers the first causes
of all causes
I guess the every striving towards
you would call philosophy every type of
striving right as what they mean by
every striving towards knowledge okay so
maybe I didn't miss a word anyways the
point is that Plato
looked at it as acquisition of knowledge
and Aristotle looked at it is causes and
principles in other words like we have
to establish the foundations of
something of whatever it is that we're
trying to establish but we have to
establish some foundations and he calls
it causes and principles and in the
summary there is philosophy is the
science notice they use the word science
philosophy is the science right science
meaning knowledge because that's what
science means right science is a synonym
of the word knowledge it can't come from
Syria from the Latin from the Romans
that referred to this thing we call
science they refer to it as Siri or
knowledge which considers first and
universal causes wisdom considers the
first causes of all causes yeah we're
talking about God or Big Bang I don't
know what they're referring to there but
the point here is it considers universal
causes now you know under the rational
scientific method causes a strictly
physics and these guys are assigning
that to philosophy so just keep that in
mind in the back way you know correct
yeah but keep that in the back of your
mind we I have a difference there okay
and now let's go to the next step says
in general this comes also from the
Catholic Encyclopedia they just kind of
synthesizes they say in general modern
philosophers may be said to have adopted
this way of looking at it in other words
they pretty much follow Plato and
Aristotle here's the cart by the term
philosophy we denote the pursuit of
wisdom pretty much like you know the
other two guys Locke John Locke
philosophy is the true knowledge of
things Bishop Berkeley the study of
wisdom and truth can't a science of the
science again right studied up of the
general principles of knowledge and of
the ultimate objects attainable by
knowledge and Hegel and other German
philosophers which
we're very popular in the 19th century
brushing in the first half it is the
general teaching of science what is
science knowledge right
and then Spencer another philosopher
completely unified knowledge okay so
obviously everybody's pretty much from
Greek all the way to the German
philosophers of the 19th centuries and B
not beyond they looked at philosophy as
the study of knowledge or related to
knowledge in some ways to be like the
overarching term of the bag that holds
all yeah in everything we've ever known
kind of like the internet the Internet
is philosophy okay so so now we have a
general idea that philosophy somehow is
related to knowledge or knowledge is a
strong word within this term that we're
going to define called philosophy
knowledge or wisdom or truth changeable
correct and and so okay so let's get to
it let's see what we mean by knowledge
and here it is now it's being a
primitive fact of consciousness cannot
strictly speaking be defined that's the
Catholic Encyclopedia here's the
Wikipedia the definition of knowledge is
a matter of ongoing debate among
philosophers in the field of
epistemology in philosophy the study of
knowledge is called epistemology Plato
famously defined knowledge as justified
true belief though this definition is
now thought by some analytic
philosophers to be problematic several
definitions of knowledge and theories to
explain it exist in other words we have
many versions of what knowledge is to
different people and we don't have a
definition of the word knowledge under
you know any possible you know a source
and and so yeah so we have philosophy as
the study of knowledge or related to
knowledge but we don't know what
knowledge is that's where we are at
today we have like a fun
it's one of the years if I say knowledge
someone else kind of knows what I mean
it's kind of know kind of knows what now
kinda knows what knows means okay okay I
got it
see you see why I had to define the what
philosophy is and also what knowledge is
I have defined the word knowledge and
people don't like my definition
obviously because it destroys their
religion that's the only reason besides
you know I'm in charge I'm the boss I'm
the guy who decides what is true and
what is not true so I overrule you okay
so period that's the end of the
discussion there okay so I had to define
what philosophy is and obviously you
know I've I have a different idea of
what philosophy is and again I try to
relate it to science because I'm saying
philosophy is is part of science it's a
branch of science and the purpose is to
deal with concepts reasons and purpose
those are the mainstream what are we
talking about when we're here let me put
the chart first up here okay so that you
can follow along but here's the chart
real quick branch of science correct
correct that's true and I'm saying it's
one of the two branches there's only two
branches of science one is physics and
the other one is philosophy okay I'll go
be it's important because see people
consider religion a philosophy or part
of philosophy or related to philosophy
I'm saying religion has nothing to do
with philosophy as defined by rational
philosophy by a rational scientific
method okay what does rational science
do it explains poom
period dot stop science is about
explaining not about describing not
about your opinions not about your
believes it's about objectively
explaining a mechanism or cause in the
case of physics and about you know
reasons and purpose in the case of
philosophy it's got to be rational what
do we mean by rational well I've defined
that in a previous discussion but in
general terms it's for the purposes of
physics you don't want to use concepts
as objects that's that's the main one
but then you have to have definitions
you can't use words that are undefined
or that are loosely defined and allow
you to get through a loophole or through
a tangent you have to define them
rigorously if they make your case we
need to know what that word means for
you or the for the purpose of your
theory and then and then also the theory
has to follow from your assumptions in
the case of physics very straightforward
the prosecutor cannot present a knife
and then you know talk about you know
how the guy was killed with poison or
with a gun you know you you it doesn't
follow from what he presented as you
know as his exhibits so there's gotta be
a relationship between the theory and
the assumptions okay so if you present
the knife as part of your assumptions
you know that it's got to do with the
crime you can't lay it around say oh she
died you know because she drank poison
you know there's no relationship to what
you presented and so so these things
have to be kept not only for physics but
also for philosophy there's got to be a
relationship between the theory the
explanation and the assumptions that you
made as the foundations for that theory
that follows from if B falls from a you
can't half way through make C fall from
yeah it's it's gonna have some kind of
logic you gotta be able to you as the
audience who are listening to the theory
you gotta be able to make sense of it no
you know what it is is the presenter has
to set a set of rules that he himself is
a programming
you write code and then you have to
abide by the code that you put forward
right the assumption is basically the
rules that you put you know these are
the these are the rules that are met put
you know and all sudden you start
breaking your own rules now we got a
problem yeah and and and again if you
look at that rational science okay
deals on one hand and deals with physics
which is the part I'm concerned with I'm
not interested in philosophy at all I'm
not interested in analyzing what love is
or how love does things I'm not
interested in why purpose reason someone
went to town he went to buy clothes
shoes did he buy it went there to buy a
car that he you know go there because he
fought with his wife and his and he just
needed some time to think about I don't
care about those subjects they don't
concern me
I do like history and why you know
people do things in history why Kings
killed their wives and vice versa or why
a general went to a battlefield those
things I'm interested in to some degree
you know what I do is you know I keep
them that's a hobby
that's not my profession let's put it
that way but physics is my profession
physically what I like to do and this is
this is where my heart is and I deal
with objects causes and mechanism but
then I needed a word to represent you
know these concepts reasons and purpose
and as you can see I put objective on
the bottom of those two piles and I'm
saying that you know an explanation has
to be objective Johnny went to town to
buy a car and the other guy said well I
have a different theory what's your
theory well my theory is Johnny went to
town to buy some shoes or to escape his
wife you know these are theories and
it's objective it's straightforward well
there's a real quick as theories
answering a question yeah in a way it is
it's a why or how I would say any
science is by definition my definition
it has to be answering a question yeah
yeah you're trying to answer a question
you're trying you're trying to explain
how something happened but that's what
explaining is you're answering a
question yeah in other words what I'm
saying is the the question you're
answering in physics what happened how
would happen the one you were talking
about Johnny okay down yeah
philosophy the answer what is the price
for Lisa
what is the reason whatever thing went
to town and you're saying that one guy
has this different and so we have that's
the context of science that's where we
should put physics and philosophy and
the purpose here is to cover concepts
and object way reasons and causes
purpose and mechanism so you would so
basically any time a question is posed
it falls under science if it's how or
why I guess I'm okay
more about that I'm not here to answer
that question
okay I know no but there could be a
question of who did this that's not a
question of philosophy who did this is
not even a question of physics because
no because it could be an opinion it's
like I'm gonna say Johnny did this and
the other guy says no Sally did this and
those are opinion then there is a person
again I have to think about it but I
think or where like in the case of
quantum mechanics they talk about where
the electron is I don't care where the
electron is it's it's got no meaning in
science as far as I'm concerned so I
don't care where the electron hands and
they say look we have an equation or a
linear equation where is the Apple well
no no but but it applies really to
because these people come up with the
equations Schrodinger's equation that we
dealt with yesterday and they say oh
this is science oh why is it science
because it tells us where the electron
is it gives us the probability weird if
I know I don't give
damn work we can find the electronic
it's not even a bead and that's my point
so not all questions are scientific I
think we should limit science the hows
and whys what what I mean by that in at
least in the case of physics is what
happened how did it happen how did the
pen fall to the floor what caused it to
fall to the floor not to the ceiling in
the case of philosophy we're dealing
with concepts you might yeah well
there's many things you can say you know
what is love or you can go into you know
a lot of philosophical issues related to
love to information to abstractions that
don't concern physics but are valid for
our science if you're gonna do and
explain you know some explaining if you
want to explain something about love
that should be you know like or
psychology why someone did something why
did he kill this person why is he crazy
why why does he have this tick or
whatever you know all these things do
involve explanations and if their
explanation they're rational
explanations they should be included
within the body of science and that's
why I put the word philosophy in there
and since no one has defined it in ten
thousand years I am free to use the word
philosophy under rational science I
would say yes if it started right
direction but I think it's far from okay
again it's a proposal and I'm not
interested in philosophy so I'm probably
not the right person to define this but
I'm I'm kicking the ball so that someone
who is interested in philosophy can take
it from there now the great problem here
is that we've all been educated to think
of philosophy as something totally
different again a love of wisdom
knowledge they put causes first cause
they put all the religion it's all
bunched up into philosophy in fact like
like my son here says you know he says
you know everything science even is
bunched up under philosophy like and and
I read once Kant quoted verbatim but
something like that
philosophy is the mother of all science
including physic it's like it's the
foundation of science you need a
philosophy all that I'm saying it's
nonsense that's the ordinary version
ordinary speech version of philosophy
now I'm defining rational philosophy
specifically I'm saying rational
philosophy is explanations that deal
with concepts reasons and purpose good
bring it on is this what do you try
what's troubling you my son okay now
let's get to let me cover that first and
then you can follow up okay now if you
look at the chart here you'll find where
I put beliefs and opinions I put it
under religion religion is not about
God's religion is not about spirits
it's not about angels about heaven or
hell it's about opinions and belief if
you have an opinion that's your religion
it's not your philosophy it's your
religion it's very subjective that's why
I put the word subjective under the
opinions and beliefs but religion also
includes irrational theories and
supernatural supernatural theories and
those could be objective or subjective
doesn't matter they're still religion
because they have nothing to do with
rational rationality now let's let's
look at these what is an irrational
theory let's go with supernatural first
supernatural theory is one where the
object is a valid object for example God
and I think of God as a human being as a
you know we're made in His image so he
looks like us he looks like a human he's
got a head two arms two legs you know
etc he's got a magic wand he creates the
universe no problem visualizing the
entire scene I can
understand the theory that the guy is
trying to give me because he begins by
showing look this is God and if you've
seen the picture the what is it the
painting made by Michelangelo you'll
you'll know what God looks like he's a
bearded guy you know he's got long hair
and he's pointing his finger you know
and he touches what's his name Adams
finger you know that God is a human
being he looks like this okay no problem
irrational theories they cannot they
cannot produce the objects and why can't
they produce the objects because they're
converting concepts into objects they
use words such as energy mass field and
they take these concepts for objects
that's why it's an irrational theory all
of mathematical physics is irrational
all of it
120% of it supernatural theories
typically the traditional religions that
looked at God and you know brought in
spirits angels that kind of thing as
long as you see an angel you know which
is a man that's got wings and a little
plate over his head well then at least
you know what object the guy is
referring to when he says the word angel
you can't do that with mathematical
physics you cannot visualize for that
mention on space time you cannot
visualize zero dimensional points or
singularities you cannot visualize one
dimensional lines or strings so all the
tools or all the objects used by
mathematical physicists are totally
irrational and their theories are
irrational because they're founded on
these okay so that's the idea religion
involves opinions beliefs which are
subjective or whether objectives are
subjective we reject irrational and
supernatural natural theories that's the
story that's that's the general
breakdown here that's why religion is
not part of philosophy not part of
rational philosophy why do you put
irrational theories under
yeah why is it under this umbrella at
all because it all falls under what I'll
call religion I want to separate
religion from rational science and again
I called it rational science and I used
the capital S for science because I want
to distinguish it from what the
mathematicians do which they call
science and which has been called
science for the last 10,000 years okay
so what do you propose tell me what you
propose magic yeah magic astrology any
of those you're all included under
religion I mean well because you can you
can break that down and say look
religion just involves opinions and
beliefs and magic involves what's on the
right side for example you could do that
and again and this is where the air is
the areas that we have been led to
believe that religion is about going to
church believing in God no religion is
belief any belief against religion I
have my religion you have you really
yeah belief is one of the aspects of
religion oh there is no religion that
has no belief that's a common belief
belief should be I want to confuse
people because I want people to think
and people don't think they just say oh
tradition says that religion is this and
and that's where it's wrong we have to
label this in some way and show that you
know we have this umbrella over here
which is science and we have this other
umbrella over here which is religion and
religion involves always believe always
opinion and it always involves or not
always but it in addition involves
irrational and super
Jero theories explanations for things
it's funny because we're kind of doing
exactly what they were talking about
with the elementary partisan and market
model we're not really doing any science
really just category we're categorize
it's helpful for the discussion and and
the reason also I do this is to make it
crisp I want to make it yes/no on off
you know on of black or white it's okay
i what i want to contrast so that people
say okay this is science and this is
religion what is religion your opinion
so when I tell you that I believe in my
theory of you know thread theory or I
believe that you know mother nature does
her work with the rope
you know electromagnetic rope that's my
religion and you should take it for such
even in the course of a dissertation if
I talked about it you say okay that part
of it his talk was religion let's get to
the meat to the to the facts to the to
the objective part what is the mechanism
he proposes that's what you gotta
concentrate on so there's no problem
mixing religion or belief you know
together with explanation with objective
explanation no problem just make sure
that you can distinguish the two and say
okay that part is the religion part the
belief part the opinion part but then
the explanation also is divided into
rational and irrational if it's rational
falls under science if it's irrational
it falls under again religion and we
have criteria for what rationality is
that is objective and that is if you use
a concept as an object that's irrational
if you did not do not define a word or
use it in consistently throughout your
dissertation that's irrational and if
your theory your explanation doesn't
follow from your assumptions from the
hypothesis that's irrational so we do
have objective criteria whether you like
it or not that's irrelevant my point
here is those are what we're proposing
for what we call
science was the word we used instead of
definition criteria criteria set of
criteria okay no criteria to make this
all black and white crisp and all show
that you distinguish and that's the main
time and that's the main point that we
can look at the chart and just get an
overall feel for what is science and
what is not and I'm saying that what is
not science will call that religion you
know you may not like the word may not
like the way I'm using these words I
don't you know it's it's not important
I'm saying that we're gonna call
religion anything which is not science
and philosophy of science therefore a
religion is not a part of Sciences
religion is a way of thinking but
philosophy is not a way of thinking
philosophy is a way of presenting in a
rational manner a theory that doesn't
involve objects in other words that does
not harp on the objects it harps on
concepts reasons and purpose okay as
long as you stay within that you're
rational and there's no reason why you
can't have a theory of like you know I
use the example of why Napoleon went to
Waterloo well maybe he went to steel
maybe he went because he wanted glory
maybe he went to die maybe he thought he
was just gonna die that was his last
battle maybe he went there because his
wife told him to go there all these
theories you've got out there fighting
but you presented in an objective manner
you don't say oh I believe that and you
should believe that you know Napoleon
went there for such and such reason no
that part is religion you just say look
my theory is this okay fine and now I
heard you now let's hear this other guy
and and then we can compare theories and
make up our own minds so science is not
about having made up your mind belief
but about understanding what the other
guy is proposing as far as an
explanation seeking not finding no no
because because you don't you know
whether you find or not that's that's
again an issue of every individual it
depends on your biases depends on your
you know your formation your education
many
factors and so everybody's going to draw
something different from an explanation
and they're gonna believe different
things and in fact different aspects of
the same explanation that's fine but
that part is religion that's what you
what is truth to you what they've proven
to you personally
you know but we should separate that
from the objective part which is what is
the mechanism and again you know when we
go back to quantum mechanics they don't
have an objective mechanism for how a
blue one pulls two quarks together this
example saying you know that's why isn't
that part of science because under no
circumstance can they produce a
mechanism where particle pulls two
particles together so that's why that
falls under you know religion it falls
under the irrational explanation part of
religion okay okay yeah go ahead okay
which is the assumptions usually follow
from beliefs in fact but that's
irrelevant because what I'm explaining
when I'm explaining objectively to you I
don't say I believe no you should say
look I'm gonna make an assumption that
God exists what do I mean by that well
that's defined exist well physical
presence object that has location so
we're saying God is an object and he has
location birth not freedom as a he right
a man okay so so we're done we've
covered that base and now you explain
your theory how did he make the universe
or wiser wiser you know Rose so perfect
well because he made it that way he
tailored it that way fine then you can
understand what the guy is proposing
whether you believe in his explanation
or not that's a separate issue but you
can follow his explanation because you
have the objects you have the God you
have the Rose you say okay I know what
he's talking about you know you
understand you
you have communication there's knows the
word that knows mrs. believes
assumptions and understanding the only
way someone can really understand what
you're saying is that they're kind of if
they can understand the assumption to
understand an assumption you've got to
be already like 99% of the way and then
I'm just gonna change you know the god
part you know the assumption I'm gonna
take on board the the god part like okay
I don't believe in God but let's assume
it right but but 99% of the way like we
both kind of have the same idea of what
we're talking in maybe maybe because you
could introduce something new like they
introduce new words in quantum every day
I mean you saw the other day we have
exotic atoms what the hell does that
term mean well it means that instead of
a mere electron you have a muon or
whatever playa so so they introduced new
terms and you have to more or less you
know present it at the assumption stage
you say look I'm gonna be talking today
I'm gonna be explaining something today
that concerns exotic atoms the guy says
what is an exotic atom I never heard of
that okay the next item is this so the
guy he finds in you said okay now I
underst
makes a picture of it's a object he
gives you a picture of it you know and
you say okay I understand now now I can
follow your presentation okay it does
mean you're gonna believe in it just
means now I'm gonna try to understand
what you're talking about that's the
question I use a baseball bat well
there's a couple things it again what do
you get for someone to understand the
assumptions he's talking about we're
still at the hypothesis stage okay it
takes a picture and it takes definitions
above all those two are non-negotiable
for physics let's start at physics okay
because then we have a philosophy but
for physics you present the object you
know I want to talk about magnetism I
start with magnets I'm saying this is a
magnet okay and first I show it
and then I might have to describe it and
say look it's got certain magical powers
it does this this and that
and then I have to define the key terms
that I'm gonna be using you know if I'm
gonna use the word field fine use the
word field what is a field and then I
have to define that word and say okay
this is what it means so that you can
follow but you have to define it in the
way that they understand correct okay
but you define and the guy might say
well I still don't understand you
defined it a little more and I still
don't understand until the guy
understands the concept and of course
he's welcome to challenge that I can
present God as an object I can say God
is a human beings got two arms a head
legs you know body well what do you mean
you mean God is like me well he's a
little more supernatural he's you know a
big guy out there he he's beyond the
universe so I got explained a little bit
it's not sufficient that I just show a
picture of God I got to give him some
properties and that's where you you have
to kind of work on your hypothesis
because the person's gonna question you
didn't on believer the guy who has
problem understanding that there is a
human out there that has all these
magical powers
he might question you why did can he do
this why does he have total amounts can
he do this can he do that
so there's gonna he's gonna bombard you
with questions to try to get an
understanding of who this God guy is
that's an interesting and accepting
temporarily accepting the conceding
brand easy and granting it's like at
what point young grant but I mean for
sure you have to understand everything
at least what point you say okay I don't
need to know so much nitty-gritty I'm
just gonna grant and that depends on
every listener in other words some some
reporters ask more questions and other
reporters others say you understand
right we referred away seem so far like
my god and maybe that's sufficient to
understand the theory as long as you
have enough information to understand
the theory you don't have to play
devil's advocate the advocacy to an
extreme level yeah okay I understand
that what you're talking about
continue with your theme and the
question goes how do they know that
they've understood enough that might
yeah you might you might have to go back
and forth and say okay then I have
from your hypothesis your assumptions
because now use here now I didn't know
how you were gonna use it in your theme
you now that I know your theory let's go
back to your hypothesis and that's
question then that's okay go back and
fashion it's a debate it's a discussion
you know and again many many presenters
say look hold all questions until the
end yeah that's it sometimes you got to
do that because maybe you cover the
bases as you go along and if you don't
then we gotta gonna ask the horse and
say okay look you started your theory
with this hypothesis with this
assumption and then you went on with
this point here that I didn't understand
because it doesn't coincide with your
assumption right and no and now you have
to clarify that point and and that's
that's the way science work that's the
discussion of science but at least as a
primer as a foundation I think you have
to have objects you have to have
definitions and you have to have you
know the initial scene as I call it you
have to have a starting point in your
movie say look this is where we're
starting these are the objects setter
this is where their position this is how
I'm gonna start my movie and this is
what I'm gonna explain with this movie
the mechanism the cause or mechanism
explain that's real science just going
back and forth and really trying to get
to the bottom we're not debating we're
not arguing it's more is a discussion
yeah I find those three differently you
know a debate is when you're talking to
each other for someone else an argument
is when you're doing it for you know
together okay I call it all discussion
debate I come off on a tangent and you
might not understand some bit of it
because because you didn't understand
Department I understood something about
my assumption that you didn't understand
okay and then we clarify that because
then that's when you go deeper into that
little thing because it might be
troubling one guy has a
different idea of what that thing is or
means to him and the other person has a
different me or or has a different angle
to it and that's where you kind of
converge upon finally a point where
there's a meeting of the minds so many
times you said something there what guys
it's not say no no then we're not
communicating here because you know
we're not on the same page yet you know
we don't have a meeting of the minds and
sometimes you have to you know they set
that little point because it's a
troubling you know it's it's an obstacle
to understanding but then there's the
format I think the way it should work or
the way science does work is I think you
start with a presentation where you have
to present a subject so that it then
goes to the public for debate
then you debate it see look at the peer
review system how does it work you write
a paper that's your presentation your
your manuscript you submit it and a
group of you know monks Oh covered quote
up because you know they're anonymous
you don't know who they are and they go
out there and debate it based on their
vision of what you're explaining is you
know I don't like this this goes against
my religion I was brought up differently
I don't agree with any of this
so they chuck it okay well there's no
discussion because your paper ended up
in the trash can and then we got
published well they understood it in
their own way and they don't like the
understanding they didn't like the other
if you explain something to someone
right yeah but if you didn't be thrown
in the trash yeah but then we have a
problem because the discussion should be
worldwide everybody should be able to
you know that's we were discussing some
about that the Internet in something I
presented today that the Internet should
be the correct peer-review system you
have a theory you put it out there and
the world evaluates it everybody gets
his own thing everybody can ask
questions not this group of six you know
mathematician saying oh were the judges
we're gonna judge whether your stuff is
scientific and if it doesn't have an
equation we do throw it in the trash
actually that's very interesting this is
there's it's kind of like the Miss
Universe contest things like that where
instead of because there's two different
judges there's the group of judges and
then there's the world right if three
judges tell you you look ugly but the
world is all telling you look beautiful
but that's why a lot of these young
Sikhs hooded monks now you the year is
arash arash yeah but everyone else likes
it the world basically it's like and I'm
not saying it's it's a popularity yeah
it's not a Mario so he gives you it's
not it's not the more people like you if
you if it's the world so that's why it's
a better theory it's more like the world
is more objective than a group of people
always if if necessarily yeah because if
strangers on the street tell you man you
got a big nose right or if you go to a
convention of big nose people and say oh
no you have a small nose see now you now
to a small group of people who are
criticizing your nose against the whole
world it's like the whole world gives
you a more except that all the world is
not always well educated as well they
always get a gradient of education I
always tell you research yeah but see
you got no no yeah I'll get there at
least
that your the way that you're explaining
is wrong but say you got a gradient of
of capacity out there of what many
people don't do research they just have
opinions and so they again they
introduce their religion their beliefs
into a scientific context and they don't
realize you know you're dealing with
believes he not what mechanism I'm
talking here about a mechanism this guy
said oh I don't believe it never you
believe it did you understand it not 90%
of the people may be dumb blonds
probably but then your science is wrong
no the 90% are wrong no no no you can't
have 90% of people believe in the
flenders
I'm not talking about the theory I'm
talking about the way you're explaining
the theory if no one's understanding it
and they all have a gripe because of
something it could be that they don't
have the foundations to understand okay
no no but then the these 90% that's
assuming that's the king the number game
just pulled it out of thin air here
let's assume this 90% does not have the
foundations of what science is or they
have a different idea because they were
educated in a given way okay or not
educated at all for that matter maybe
they're illiterate and so these people
are gonna vote for your theory and say
well I don't like your theory well you
don't like me you didn't understand it
well why didn't I understand well
because you have a different mentality
of how science is supposed to work you
think science is belief and that's
religion so you get to clarify these
points upfront and it's not always you
know I don't think you agree with that I
guess I guess it goes back to it's the
best you're gonna get I mean there's no
more people than the world to tell you
what you're doing well that's where you
get sick wellit's is the man and that's
more or less what Plato talked about he
said philosopher Kings it's a group of
people up there who know and the masses
don't but do you see and so we can't put
this to a vote
democratically because it won't work but
it's a problem with there's pros and
cons to
correct totally totally agree there you
can't you can't circumscribe knowledge
we'll call it that explanations science
we can't circumscribe science to an
elite and at the same time you know you
do want the world to understand or to
participate in the process of science
but voting is probably should be
outlawed because voting again means that
you're going to go into beliefs into
whether I believe your theory not
whether you understood it if we're
talking about understanding there could
be a lot of people that don't understand
it because they don't have the
foundations to understand that's a
different subject for it is that you
know yeah but you're doing some thinking
I see all that it's because you're using
this word foundations but that's
achieved those foundations is part of
your theory well no no I don't think
well they don't understand foundation is
not a theory and and let's clarify that
foundation is not an opinion first of
all it's not a theory we're gonna say
look we have too deep no it's a
definition it's criteria which is an
assumption definitions are also
assumptions it is part of the
assumptions but but we have to define
and if you don't define then the other
guys gotta define someone's gotta be
fighting but understand the way you use
the words which is part of the
assumption okay correct he's got to
understand my version of science I got
to start there and say look this is my
version of science and the guy's got to
start my understanding yeah yeah yeah
because you can't just jump in and say
look you know I have a theory and the
guy says well I don't believe in your
theory well I don't care if you believe
in my theory because you're dealing with
religion science only deals with
mechanisms all you got to do is
understand it not believe it and so you
got to start there and that's very hard
for people to understand already right
there because most people believe that
science is about believing they they
have no difference between science and
religion that's why we have this
little chart rational science chart as I
call it where we categorize these thing
and said oh you are we gonna do religion
beliefs opinion irrational theories
supernatural theories or are we gonna do
science which is either physics or
philosophy will deal with objects causes
and mechanisms under physics and
concepts reasons and purpose under
philosophy then you have its
circumscribed and say look do you
understand the Meccans if the guy says
well you might say one of two things you
might say I understand it I don't agree
with it or I don't understand it so so
that's that's the first thing you have
to clarify because you can't you can't
move up to the theory if the guy doesn't
even have the foundations of what
science is yeah and then he's got to
provide in alternatives okay then that's
that science what do you mean by
understand
forget is because something's going
the guy has a problem in in the sense
that he's got a different vision of the
universe of what science and religion
and whatever is and so please tell me
what you think is science what you think
is religion as they help him understand
it might because now you get into a
debate and show him where he's got
faults in his thinking process you got
to show him that he's got a problem with
the way he's presenting the word science
that word religion so he's got a bug in
his head which is and what I'm saying
please tell me what you're thinking you
know what is your version bottom-up yeah
so let's see let's we get to the same
page what don't you understand what
don't you understand about understanding
science yeah and again we all have
different foundations you know a guy
who's born in Vietnam he's educated
probably differently in many ways than
you are who are maybe an American or a
Mexican or whatever
rushon no no no no in general terms
remember these people have a different
philosophy
they have different traditions in in in
what has come down to them maybe from
Buddhism from Indu ISM or whatever and
that's kind of different than the
notions of these religions which were
the original philosophies you could say
they were different than what came out
in the West you know you have we came
out of Mythology Greek mythology when we
went into Roman mythology and from there
we we eventually extrapolated or
invented you know monotheism you know
one God you know and we came up with
Christianity and Christianity broke up
later in pieces but you know brought the
Protestantism Orthodox religion
Christianity they're all pretty much the
same name they think of this one God out
there and so and and from there then we
came up with a scientific part which
supposedly he said we're gonna do
experiments and try to explain them and
forget about all the supernatural stuff
and what we did is just enter you know
irrationality we ended up with all these
concepts that we move around today so
that's the way this thing has evolved
but then you know a person in the West
who's educated under Western criteria
has already a foundational difference
from someone in who's educated under
Eastern philosophy religion etc and so
it doesn't mean that we're all educated
in the same way and you kind of have to
get on the same page before you can even
start explaining your theory and say
look this is what we're gonna call
science this is what we're gonna call
religion you gotta make it black and
white on and on yes or no brainwash in a
different way than you were
okay so let's summarize here I just want
to get the main point across and the
main point that I'm trying to make today
is that rational philosophy not the
philosophy we've had in last 10,000
years we're talking about a new meaning
a new definition for the word
Lassa fever hit well yeah well we'll
call it we'll call it a term we'll call
it rational philosophy to distinguish it
from philosophy so if there's you know
that helps you separate the two well
rational philosophy again just in
general terms in me we may not get to
the bottom of it but let's just make
sure we understand this rational
philosophy is part of rational science
that means philosophy is only going to
deal with explanations what do we
explain do we explain gravity do we
explain you know magnetism no those are
those are subjects that fall under
physics unless those are people's names
right philosophy only deals with
concepts reasons and purpose ok concepts
you may be talking about love you may be
talking about information abstract
straight we'll call them abstract
concepts ok abstraction compared to
physicality with physics it's always
attached to a question ok is because you
can have a concept in a question about
physics can you have a concept in a
question about physics can you have an
object in the question about philosophy
there are there are lines that are
crossed but we got to keep remember
again I when I give a presentation I'll
introduce my beliefs and you say oh but
that's religion you're talking about
religion yeah that portion that little
portion that's belief that's that's
religion and so all you have to do is
say ok now he's talking about religion
now he's talking about philosophy now
he's talking about physics as long as
you can put that more or less into
proper context you're OK no but it's
deeper because if you say the object
moved no no no and again it is yeah it
it first of all it is a concept yeah
it's a relation no doubt about that
existed all these words are concepts but
we're not dealing with the concept
itself we're not saying what is
but we are asking what his motion but
were the purpose of defining these terms
of putting criteria there is for the
purposes of physics philosophy deal with
something else who deals with why did I
do something what was the purpose that's
one way of looking at another one is you
know you talk about love are you talking
about what psychology why someone does
something that won't behavior you know
and and that's a little different than
saying well did he move how did I know
what do you mean by emotion know that
that part is physic what is motion of
motion is of concept so that's the
problem
yeah but see again we're not talking
about the concept itself when we say
look a rock moved no no one question is
what is motion what does that question
falling again it's a definition that can
be used if you need it it's a definition
that you can use either in philosophy or
physics if we use it in physics we're
just gonna refer to the object that
moved if you're gonna use it in
philosophy I'm not even sure what you
can use the word motion and philosophy
what is motion define the word and use
it for something else
it is the end in itself what every word
in the dictionary concept every word and
every definition is a concept what else
do you need now because I want to know
the graph is is missing some pieces
because you're not talking about the
questions that what what we call science
or sorry what we call physics or what we
call philosophy points that the question
being asked right so so you have to
actually put question marks in this
graph that you show this table it's not
deals with objects because everything
deals with oh yeah but that's a computer
that means you didn't understand no no
no no because you're making it buzzy no
you say
it we heart on yeah objects that's fuzzy
because you think we're harping on
objects but I think we're harping on on
philosophy it now it's just an opinion
on what we're harping on on what the
main absolutely now this is objective
this is totally objective and physics
deals only with objects and the movement
of objects and we're looking at causes
and mechanism we have to define the
terminology is a is a definition a
concept all definitions or concepts nah
that doesn't mean that physics deals
with motion per se and say well what is
motion no we define and say look we're
gonna talk about objects I'm gonna say
this moved and and the guy says what do
you mean by move then I define it and it
serves as a foundation for physics but
physics doesn't concentrate on the
concept motion it concentrates on the
movement of objects because you need the
word to explain what you why the object
moved or how the MA object movement how
it caused an effect I'm saying that the
chart is is kind of fuzzy because we're
talking about questions okay question
explain this now we have to discern does
that question fall under philosophy or
does it fall and what's the problem and
the problem is this chart doesn't tell
us if the question itself is it's not a
comprehensive chart to point the
question to Warner the other because I
thought it did
tell me where it doesn't that's what I
wanted you know me if you ask what is
motion motion
what is motion what is motion is that no
we define motion why can't because we're
not gonna use the word motion I am to
like we're not gonna if the word motion
to harp on the word motion we're going
to lose the one if you want to talk
about motion then it's it's gonna be
philosophy because you're talking about
a concept you're gonna dissect the word
motion but that's not physics physics is
here's a definition now I know what the
word moved me and I wanna say a rock
moved and that we're not concentrated
under word most of our concentrating
kinda
and what it did and motion is the word
you need to explain that if you know
what under what branch does the question
what is motion fall under and you said
it's philosophy what is motion if you're
gonna put a definition and if you're
gonna harp on just the definition and
you're gonna dissect the word motion it
falls under philosophy yeah I said all
concepts are defined and that's why
concept is properly under philosophy all
concepts are defined all definitions
fall under philosophy all of them but
the fact that once we define it now
we're gonna use it as the foundation of
physics we're not gonna harp on the
concept location on the concept motion
on the concept distance we're not gonna
harp on the concept we're not gonna
analyze the concept we're gonna harp on
saying these two objects have distance
between them we're gonna use the word
now in physics yeah but but you keep
turning my question into a definition
question yeah I wanna know what do we
like what is motion is is is the answer
to that question definition it is a
definition it's a concept so it's gotta
be defined all concepts are defined
where those concept fall terrible Lassa
but so anytime we're asking a what is
something what is the words what is and
then an underlined put a concept here
yeah but holds always a definition quite
good by it no but yeah but be careful
with that because the the word what is
very confusing for concepts well that's
why we can't use the word what what is
only objects only not in physics not in
ordinary speech when you say what in it
I don't know what I said let me finish
the condo what I'm gonna say the word
what should not be used like it used it
is used in ordinary speech in ordinary
speech we say what do you mean by this
what is this what is we use the word
what wrong you can't use that in science
in science you say how do you define
this word what is the definition
of this word you weren't you what are
the criteria for this definition but in
what in in physics what is an object
whenever you say what your repair only
jobs he you you'll not refer to concepts
you can't say what is love not in
physics you can say what is a rock
that's okay philosophy and then you have
a definition but you can't say in
philosophy what is a rock no because in
in physics you have to present a picture
of Iraq and say that's a rock you point
to objects you don't define them but
then the question is still valid
what is motion or what is love wrong you
can't say what if you put a concept at
the end of that it becomes a no correct
way to formulate and that's use the word
what because the word what is misleading
what is a rock is a good term you can't
say what is love not in science that in
rational saying that's ordinary speech
you say what is the definition you can
say that give me the definition you
don't use the word what give you the
definition of love why can't you say
what is love
because what is a physical object what
always have to refers only to objects
you can't say well you can say what is a
table you can't say what is love what is
love already means oh he's talking about
physical object that's the problem the
word what is very misleading you gotta
be careful with the what wisenhouse we
tend to bring ordinary speech in there
and that's where it becomes a serious
problem what no not for love you can say
defining love you find a word love with
that question from Dan is there an
equivalent for concepts of the word
exist as in some concepts are more
abstract than others a bit like some
objects are non-existent
well yeah but there is their equivalent
for concepts of the word exist yeah yeah
the content exists has synonyms like
real
no no he's asking is it like love we all
know what love is or we all have
have a somewhat gist of what it is but
if I come up with a new concept that no
one knows maybe it's it's it's less real
some concepts are more abstract all
concepts are abstract the concepts are
all abstract I mean you know all
concepts again we define concepts and
point to objects pointing to objects
that's physics defining concepts that's
philosophy but that doesn't but once you
define the concept once you get them to
what the word love means now the
question is can you use that in physics
or can use that in philosophy and love
is used in philosophy and physics deals
only with objects but other natta you
know I'm not understanding well the
question there
it's got to be phrased in a better way
concepts are more abstract they're all
abstract okay anyways that's the general
picture we'll see you tomorrow same time
same station we'll see you that bye bye